uh particularly as I think transparency
is very important uh this morning and so
I should say that uh in the 70s and 80s
I was a BBC journalist and in the 90s I
was a policy advisor to John Burt any
other day yes I'm a former BBC reporter
and uh news uh presenter and news anchor
four BBC presenter and manager
the BBC for some years and I'm
occasionally in receipt of uh
royalties I was a very Junior person at
yielding house in the 90s
I have attended events and received
Hospitality from the BBC in the past
I I have attended events and research
Hospitality although not in the last
year I don't think okay thank you oh and
welcome to Richard Sharp the chair of
the BBC thank you for agreeing to come
before us this morning
um I want to start by trying to
establish the facts of about the loan
arrangement with the then prime minister
which was being set up at the same time
as he was making the appointment of the
the BBC chair essentially from what I've
read there were three people involved
Sam Blythe Boyce Johnson and and you Mr
Sharp who started the whole procedure
who approached who first well
um first of all thank you very much for
giving me the opportunity to clarify
these issues because as you say there's
some confusion and I should point out I
believe it was actually two years ago
that
um I was subject to the scrutiny for the
appointment it wasn't wasn't a year ago
um the and I also want to make it clear
uh that I've never given Financial
advice to the former prime minister he's
never asked for it he never received it
from me and I'll get into the details of
our relationship
the starting point uh in in the way you
described it is my long-standing
relationship and friendship with Mr
Blythe is something I met after he'd
left University and after I'd left
University some 40 years ago
um so Mr Blythe is a personal friend of
mine who I've known for some time
as a result of press reports that he had
read in September
um he raised with me
at that time his concern
that his cousin
the prime minister
was reported in these press reports to
have some difficulties
um Mr Blythe raised with me the fact
that he was interested in in feeling
about whether he should he do something
to help
he raised that with me at a private
dinner at his house
I said to him at that time
you may be a family member
but you need to be very careful things
need to be done by the book
There are rules in this country and
these rules exist for a good reason
you're a foreigner
and therefore before you contemplate
doing anything
or providing any assistance to the prime
minister
you should involve the cabinet office
and that was the he raised that issue
with me and that was the end of it at
that point in time
and that was in September yes correct so
what was the position then with your uh
seeking the BBC chairmanship okay well
so I should explain when the pandemic
arose
um there was clearly a national economic
crisis
and the then Chancellor asked me whether
I would
um
support come and work for him as a
special economic advisor
to the treasury
um and in supporting Industries uh in
particularly large companies as they
needed Capital to survive during the
pandemic
um so I focused on Industries such as
Steel Etc we can go into more detail but
at that time therefore I was working
because of the pandemic the operations
run out of number 11 Downing Street
which is as you know is a connected
office
with the um uh with number 10 Downing
Street and the cabinet officers a sort
of related thing so
um uh I was working there and then
during that period of time
um
roundabout I think October
the existing
speculated front runner uh Charles Moore
for the chairmanship with Drew now I had
at that time I should also say be
working on special film Insurance keep
the film industry going which uniquely
in this country we achieved with 50 to
100 000 jobs at stake
and and also the cultural Recovery Fund
putting that in place to support
throughout the country cultural
institutions and that put me in contact
with a lot of people from the media
world
um and uh and albeit in my prayer we
discussed this before my prior uh uh
working experience I had worked uh in
with media companies
um this was a new experience for me so
and some of some of my uh friends at
that time uh suggested to me
um that I should think consider applying
for the job so I was working in in uh in
effect at home and in Downing Street it
was during the pandemic and if I can
remind you it was before the first
vaccine it may have just been discovered
but it hadn't been provided but it was
pretty clear to me that a lot of the
bulk of the work that I had had to do I
had done
and I was very interested in the
prospect of working uh submitting my
application to be the chair of the BBC
and I did so so this was happening at
pretty much the same time so you've been
told by sunglide in September that that
yeah he taken your advice as to whether
he should help the Prime Minister yes
and in the following weeks you thought
okay I'm I'm up for this job yes because
because because in a sense that's what
what's relevant
um
because given that you you clearly you
say in September then you realized that
there were propriety issues involved
did it not occur to you at that point
that because you were applying for a job
that the prime minister of the day would
appoint that you should say to him look
whatever you want to do
that's fine that's a matter for you but
I can't be involved because I'm applying
to be chair of the BBC it may it may be
um it's almost hard to recall the time
then but actually what what happened at
that point
through a call was there was another
lockdown we worked from him so you
worked or worked in the office if you
needed to
um so I was working and I to me that was
an after dinner party comment and that
was no more than that and that was that
was the last day I'd had at that point
from Mr Blythe on the matter I didn't
see him after that
so you never discussed it with him after
September no I then the next moment I
had any contact for Mr blython that
matter was when he called me and said at
that I've well I've then submitted I'm
my application I basically communicated
to the Prime Minister and to the
chancellor that I wish to apply
um and submitting my application in
November
um following that towards the end of
November I received a call from Mr
Blythe
saying that he was interested in uh
exploring with the cabinet office
what possible possibly he could do to
help his cousin
and he asked me if I put him in touch
with the cabinet secretary that with
that that was a phone call I received
from him
um at that time and so what you did put
him in touch with capital yes sir I then
arranged to go
um subsequently and we can go through
the sequence I then met the cabinet
secretary and got his agreement that he
would um at least I that that I could
pass his number to I didn't follow that
I passed his number to Sam's life to um
get in contact with the cabinet office
so your meeting with with Simon case the
cabinet secretary was purely to discuss
whether
would speak to Sam's life yes it was to
tell him that Mr Blythe was interested
was was I had spoken to Mr Blythe Mr
Blythe wanted to explore ways that he
could help the Prime Minister
um and
um I Ray and and therefore he asked me
introduced to the cabinet secretary and
then at that meeting I raised with Mr
Bly the fact that I had submitted my
application to be the chair of the BBC
and that therefore to avoid a conflict
or perception of conflict I could have
and we agreed no further participation
in whatever transpired whatsoever and I
didn't yes so you acted as a sort of
introduction agency that well that's
well well exactly what I did was ensured
that uh due process and proprietary was
followed in in the interests of what Sam
Mr Blythe had had learned from me was
that that was an entirely appropriate
thing to do in the context despite the
fact he's a family member I should also
say I'd also mentioned to him that um he
was a foreigner and therefore there
there are there are a lot of issues that
need to be addressed that could prevent
him from providing any support
whatsoever and the best people to
address that with would be the cabinet
office hence he asked me to put Hebrew
me up asking me to put him in touch with
Mr Case
all of that
seems fine but but I'm still not clear
why you needed to go and have a meeting
with Simon case to say
there's this guy who wants to help the
Prime Minister and there may be
propriety issues so you want to talk to
him because that seems overblown no well
I was working in the same office
operation
um clearly
um uh you know Mr Mr Case didn't know Mr
Blythe at all and
um Mr Blythe wanted to have contact with
the cabinet office in the way I
described and at the other the Sunday
Times reported a dinner party attended
by you and Mr Blythe in November 2020.
did that happen no that was uh that's a
factual inaccuracy
the I mean did they just get it wrong or
yes they got it wrong and they've
acknowledged that subsequently okay
um but one other thing that's a dinner
party dinner did take place but it took
place in May
and um that was after I was the chair of
the BBC and I took and that was the
dinner I took the opportunity of as I
then subsequently discussed with the
director General to
um promote the interest of the BBC to
try and get a an effective license fee
settlement you've said this morning that
you you've never provided Financial
advice yes and yet there's a cabinet
office note from Simon case and to Boyce
Johnson and saying given the imminent
announcement of Richard Sharp As a new
BBC chair it is important that you no
longer ask his advice about your
personal financial assets that seems to
contradict what you've just said well I
haven't seen that memo when I was in the
Sunday Times I haven't seen the memo
itself I've seen the report of the memo
obviously and in fact I discussed that
with the cabinet office
what Mr Case undertook to me and I was
very grateful for that at the meeting he
was he said I will ensure you have no
further part in this
and I had no further part in this and so
that memo
um and I've in fact I discussed this
um with a cabinet official because I
only learned about this over the weekend
when when as you did when when when I a
journalist put that to me I learned from
the cabinet office it did refer to the
meeting that I'd had with Mr Johnson
which was
um alerting him to the fact that I was
going to go and seen as the case
and at that meeting I did not provide Mr
Johnson advice and um I think it was an
ambiguous construction that obviously is
open to misinterpretation I've never
given the Prime Minister advice he's
never sorted I know nothing about his
personal financial affairs and so I take
it that that phrasing and I had that
confirmed to me unofficially by the
cabinet office uh before the article was
written
was that referred to the fact that their
efforts were to prevent me from
receiving any calls from the prime
minister to protect my position and to
protect his for that matter
that's I mean that's an interesting
reading of the phrase it is important
that you no longer ask his advice about
your personal financial matters that
that clearly implies yeah that he had
asked your advice he had not yet not
asked my advice so some cases wrong well
that phrasing is wrong so I didn't you
know I don't know who wrote that memo I
don't know if Mr Case read them I heard
that somebody else might have written a
memo
um rather than Mr Case herself but I did
not provide and have not provided the
Prime Minister the former prime minister
for personal financial advice I know
nothing about his Affairs I never have
done is financial affairs and I I
wouldn't wouldn't provide him Financial
advice will you say nothing presumably
you knew because well I knew was press
reports was press reports that he had
Financial issues and U.S I have no
interest in providing in financial
advice I guess somebody who would help
me so so what my interest was to
introduce Mr Mr Blythe to Mr case
because Mr Blythe wanted to help the
Prime Minister and I wanted to ensure
that his request that there was a
process by which all the rules could be
followed appropriately
I mean did you ever give informal advice
as a friend of of Boris Johnson yeah
about that no no no uh no our
relationship is broadly professional
um and it has been broadly professional
rather than personal
that's interesting as well one of the
other things that is you know there's
been a huge amount of newspaper coverage
of this
um I read that you're you're one of the
people who actually calls him Al no it's
actually Mr it's Mr Blythe that calls
him out I call him I call him Boris
yeah so so what we've learned then is
that this
but it's a family term I gather yeah
yeah indeed no I've heard Joe called him
that but but very few others
um the so what we learned is that the
Simon case memo is just inaccurate or
the cabinet office memo and a piece of
advice for the Prime Minister about his
propriety and the propriety of his
actions was pretty glaringly inaccurate
and indeed potentially damaging to you
because you had said I've never good
than you were continuing to say I've
never given him Financial advice but
there's a cabinet office memo suggesting
you did give him Financial advice that
that that memory itself seems to me
from your point of view unbelievably
shoddy to come out under the cabinet
secretary's name well I look the I
didn't I didn't write that memo
um I don't I believe it was written by
somebody who wasn't at the meeting I had
with Mr case there was nobody at that
meeting I understand there were no
minutes taken at that meeting does that
mean it was just you and him in the room
you know I think he took notes he told
me he took some notes for example he
noted and he reminded me he he raised he
reminded me that I'd raised with him
specifically proactively the fact that I
was in
um I've been considered for the BBC
chairmanship and I raised that with him
at that meeting
and after that meeting did you ever
discuss with him or Mr Blythe or Boris
Johnson anything about his Boris
Johnson's financial affairs no
no I'd never had frankly I I hadn't
thought about it at all until a couple
weeks ago when I got called by a
journalist I had nothing to do with it
whatsoever I have not party to anything
that then happened or didn't happen
I have no knowledge of a bank I have no
knowledge of the actual loan I've had
I've no knowledge of that I'm no
interest in candidly until until I got I
was until I got a call back from the
journalist
John Nicholson uh thank you good morning
Mr Sharp good morning why did you tell
the committee of this committee that you
helped facilitate an 800 000 pound loan
for the man who then gave you this Plum
appointment that you know who I didn't
facilitate a loan you introduced it to
the person who gave the loan to him the
person who gave the loan told you that
he was going to help the prime minister
with what you call his difficulties
you facilitated it I made an
introduction knowing that it was about
money
I
introduced
Mr Blythe to Mr case I did not introduce
Mr Blythe to Mr Johnson but nonetheless
you knew what the score was and you
didn't tell us about it let me remind
you of what you signed up to on your BBC
application
it says the following you cannot be
considered if you failed to declare any
conflict of interest clearly this was a
conflict of interest it continues any
issues on your personal or professional
history that could if you were appointed
cause embarrassment or public confidence
to be jeopardized must be disclosed this
clearly causes the BBC embarrassment why
didn't you disclose it the um
just to be clear I didn't I didn't
arrange the loan I did at the meeting
helped with the loan the loan would not
have happened to presumably if you
hadn't played the role that you did
I as I said I was I was ensuring due
process was followed
I can't speculate on what would have
happened or not happened had I not had
the meeting with Mr Case
um tell us why you didn't disclose it
the the me the meeting I had with Mr
Case explicitly addressed the issue of
my
um Canada for the BBC
and um in talking to Mr case I'm talking
to the Mercedes of servant in the land
and within that area is proprietary and
ethics as you know yeah but you did
disclose it to this committee and you
clearly should have done let's um let's
continue and have a little look at the
at the timetable as the chair there'll
be plenty of time and let's try and kind
of
go through it relatively uh snapfily now
the application is closed for your job
in November the 11th I understand did
you have a meeting with Boris Johnson
before you submitted your application
about your application a meeting when he
said let's make the BBC great
you didn't discuss your job application
before you submitted it with the prime
minister
I'd like to answer the question for me
please um the I did I did go to Mr
Johnson
to tell him that I wish to apply to be
the chair of the BBC
um that was not the meeting where he
told me let's make BBC great he asked me
why I wanted to do it and I told him at
that time I wanted to do it
um and because I care about the BBC and
I thought I could make a significant
contribution I'd made a contribution
um to the treasury I'd supported the
industries I can understand why you
wanted the job Mr Chuck but I'm just
trying to get through some of the
details so you you had a meeting with
the Prime Minister before you submitted
the application no it's important to
remember who the board was for this it
included a Tory party donor plus the
wife of Boris Johnson's former spectator
chair so not exactly a hostile board
and you were such a student for this
that according to Robert peston
ministers told other applicants not to
waste time submitting their applications
so let's look at Boris Johnson's loan as
we've heard his cousin approached you at
a dinner party and said he wanted to
give Boris Johnson a lot of money
because again to use your phrase he was
in some difficulties who he did not say
that he didn't say he wanted to give him
money no he didn't he said he wanted to
help him what does that mean of course
it implies that it could be money or or
anything else he didn't say a lot of
right so let's not dance in the head of
a a pen he wanted to help him out of his
difficulties because the Prime Minister
couldn't manage on his 164 000 pound
salary
um
I'm still not quite clear why he didn't
since he was a cousin just asked Boris
Johnson directly do you want some cash
cards well again I'd say that you
um
it's probably worth recording what was
going on at the time
um we had no vaccine
we faced a national crisis
we had an economy that was collapsing
potentially
we had no vaccine
and he was concerned that his cousin
should focus on the job quite so the
cousin would have taken the phone call
uh clearly uh if if he phoned up and
said I want to help you out financially
now originally we've discussed this
um mayor come back to answer yes please
perhaps in the next answer you told
journalists that the dinner was in
November 2020 now you've said that the
journalists have said they got that
wrong the Sunday Times journalist
actually said that they think you got
that wrong in the initial briefing that
your representative gave them but that's
um we can leave that to one site because
of course it would have been illegal to
have had a dinner in November because
covert lockdown was on so you now see
that the conversation with Mr blight was
in September in other words before you
applied for the BBC Chairman's post so
Boris Johnson knew you were helping him
effectively with the 800 000 pound loan
when you applied for
um
no he didn't
he said he did he first of all first of
all I did not help with any loan just to
be clear facilitated
I think I think the detail is right now
made the introduction so where is
Johnson Boris Johnson knew that you'd
made an introduction between him and his
cousin who apparently needed introduced
to him even though he was his cousin
um and you made that introduction uh 800
000 pounds was the factor huge amount of
money and Boris Johnson knew that this
was happening was in the pipeline before
you applied for the BBC chairpost with
respect Mr Nicholson there are a lot of
things you just said are incorrect and
if I'd love if you may I'd like to
answer them in detail
please continue zero thank you
um
so when um the dinner that I had with Mr
blight was in September
and at that time there was no figure
mentioned at all there was no mention of
it being a loan it was clearly Financial
but there was no specific figure and I
did I actually don't believe
that there has been any knowledge of
what
what financing has been provided and all
I have seen is Mr Blythe commenting
publicly saying that the amount
speculated is wrong so but that doesn't
mean much it could be 750 or maybe 9 50.
I knew the scale of the prime minister's
difficulties were sufficient that his
multi-millionaire cousin needed to step
in and help him so let's not dwell on
the exactly there's a lot of money I
address some of the other excuse arrays
that I think is correct
so
um as I said when I um submitted my when
I went to meet the Prime Minister and
um told him that I wanted to apply to be
the chair of the BBC
um at that point I hadn't heard from Mr
Blythe asking me to put him in touch
with Mr case so as far as I was
concerned at that time there was
something that would had happened
in a dinner party conversation in
September
and when I had the conversation with the
Prime Minister about wanting to
apply to be the chair of the BBC
um that I had no knowledge at that point
to Mr Blythe and was doing anything to
take it anything further forward so you
didn't say to the Prime Minister prime
minister your cousin's looking to tell
you no I did not
um okay so although you discussed the
loan with Mr Bly Boris Johnson's cousin
in September 2020. you didn't actually
go to see the cabinet secretary until
December so quite a long time afterwards
um at that discussion with the cabinet
secretary did anyone else attend were
any minutes taken well
this comes back to answering one of the
your earlier questions
which is at that meeting I raised with
the cabinet secretary that I was in the
application process for the BBC
championship
um and
therefore at that time we discussed
precisely
that to avoid a conflict or the
appearance of conflict I should have
nothing further to do with it
at that meeting there were two people I
was there and Mr Case was there but
nobody so nobody was taking notes now
you told the media show Mr Case was was
I believe taking notes yeah did you
you'd have expected a civil servant to
be a group there rather than the captain
secretary taking his own notes now you
taught the media show that you told
Boris Johnson you were going to see the
cabin secretary about
the Lord
so when Boris Johnson says that you knew
nothing about his financial affairs and
to quote him he was Ding Dang sure about
that that's obviously untrue
well he what he knows is that the only
information I have about his financial
affairs are saying that you have so you
knew that he was in Dire Straits
financially despite his huge salary so
and you'd been involved in a a
discussion with his cousin about that
did you tell anyone apart from the
coverage secretary about this
conversation
um with his cousin
no I didn't jockey so you didn't tell
your interview panel at the BBC uh you
didn't tell the dcms permanent secretary
because she's told the Public Accounts
committee that she'd been left
completely in the dark and as we've
established you didn't tell us but we
know that the cabin secretary was
uncomfortable because he sent a letter
telling Boris Johnson to stop seeking
Financial advice from you and you've
already covered that so I think we can
leave that but the nail biting
application process was over you had the
job
and you went off to celebrate at
Checkers now I understand that it was
some blight who invited you to Checkers
and he said and I quote do you want to
come to Checkers I'm going to dinner
with Al uh in other words Boris Johnson
so you were effectively his plus one is
that correct
um can I come back to something you said
earlier which is about the fact that
having had a conversation
with Mr Case
where I'd specifically raise the issue
of the and proactively raise the issue
of my BBC application that he had agreed
that to avoid a conflict or perceptional
conflict that the issue was resolved
by my not being in any way further
involved in any process or any
discussion about what would then
transpire and that is why at that point
as far as I was concerned the matter had
been resolved with respect for the need
for disclosure yeah but the cabinet
secretary was alarmed about this but I
want to pursue the checkers dinner for
assessment because it strikes me that
his cousin samblite and Boris Johnson
had become very Pali at this stage
um which is surprising because only a
short time previously you'd had to
introduce them effectively although they
were cousins or you'd had to you you'd
had to you'd had to act as a group
between to the extent that you've
described may I yes at those points
um
Mr blind first myth Mr Johnson when Mr
Johnson was a little boy
um he he has a I did not introduce him
to Mr Johnson I did not introduce he was
reintroduced I did not introduce Mr
Blythe to the Johnson family in any way
that he was known to them
um my I you you correctly characterized
me as I go between my as I go between I
was not between Mr blight and Mr Johnson
but I was actually seeking to ensure
that uh due process was followed by
ensuring that Mr Blyth had contact with
the cabinet office before he would do
anything to help his cousin at the
checkers uh dinner
um did you talk about the lawn no I
didn't talk about anything about the
financing or anything that transpired as
a result of any contact that Mr Blythe
would have had with the capital I've
heard you say that you talked about the
license uh fee at that dinner you talked
about the license fee your lobbied about
the license fee in front of Mr Bly yes
the cousin which seemed strange were
civil servants present no correct
when all this blew up of course the
commissioner for public appointments
William shawcross was due to investigate
and will welcome that but after a week
he recused himself because he said he'd
met you where you clearly met a lot of
people
um and I'm guessing there must be more
than that what's your relationship with
Mr shellcross
well I think I've met him in the last 15
years maybe two or three times I think
the last time I was at a dinner with him
maybe over a decade ago
um but he's so
um
I know of him I know some of his
relatives by marriage
um have you ever been in business with
him no have you ever discussed business
with him no his daughter is a senior
number 10 Aid and his son-in-law Simon
Wilson like you is a is a Tory uh donor
so have you do you think that's the
reason that he's refused himself have
you spoken to him about why he refused
himself no I haven't okay well you
resign if the inquiry
criticizes you for withholding
information well I'll need to see what
the inquiry produces what if inquiry
says you should have told
um you should have told the members of
the interview panel about the the loan
that you helped facilitate the
introductions that you made if they said
that you should have told this committee
they'll be pretty clear will you resign
would well just to be clear
um I was subject to a very rigorous
interview process
um I needed to be considered
um appointable if you like and
recommendable as you know from Lord
daker's experience
any preferences
don't necessarily guarantee that
independent committees form that view
and I'm confident that in that sense
that Not only was I appoint to my merits
but also I'm confident that my
subsequent performance at the BBC
although you previously applied for a
job in in the BBC board am I right I
applied to be a non-executive they had a
different structure at that time yes and
I applied to be a non-executive on the
management board not the governance
board and you didn't get the job I
didn't actually get an interview at that
time what do you think the difference
was between your failed application then
and your application now following the
um the huge facility that you helped the
prime minister with I did not help the
prime minister with a huge Facility have
you any idea how angry BBC staff
are with you
look I'm I regret
the distractions has caused there's no
doubt about that and and certainly I'm
you know
disturbed by the fact that all the
tremendous things that the BBC is doing
should any way be overshadowed by this
I'm sure like most of the rest of you
who I mean well they're absolutely
Furious and I've had a huge meal bag
problem BBC staff about it and a
recurring question one of many things
they're angry with you about is the fact
that you're not a journalist but
inexplicably chose to sit on the
selection panel for the head of news
position
would you like me to address that issue
is there a question there yes do you
understand why they're angry about that
well if they're angry about that then
they don't don't actually understand and
we need to do a better job of explaining
the governance of the BBC as it
currently is
um
yes okay so the
we have a unitary board
and I'm the non-executive chairman now
the detail matters so for example if you
look at Netflix they have an executive
chairman
and the non-executive often gets
overlooked in terms of meaning in
corporate governance but really what it
is is to draw a bright line between the
executive and how they execute and the
board in terms of owning the strategy
and the issues the board deals with
and in a unitary board and this detail
is very important in terms of governance
the board has set the critical functions
to do and if you look at those functions
they critically own the strategy
they are in the creative remit for BBC
they own the budget
and they ensure value for money they
have to have and this goes to our
purposes a framework for assessing the
BBC's UK public services including the
world servers
they have to have a policy on the
distribution of the Public Services
no I want to pursue that point
um you were you were on the board for
the director news that is a journalistic
appointment uh it is not appropriate
I don't think and BBC staff don't think
for you to be on the board for a
journalistic appointment albeit that it
has board implications it was
fundamentally a journalistic appointment
and I think if I could summarize really
yeah I'll let you come back after this
what are polls I think so many BBC staff
is that you got this job with no BBC
experience they knew about the bus
Dimensions to the Tory party that you've
given but they didn't know about the 800
000 pounds something that you withheld
from the interview panel the dcms
permanent secretary and this committee
and I think it leaves the impression so
much of this is
is deeply establishment it's Paul's
appointing Pals donating money to polls
uh and and I think as I said in the
chamber it rather leads the impression
um that it's all about it's all about
Banana Republic and cozy may I come back
to the question of the appointment of
the head of news which I think is quite
critical and the reason I was outlining
the board responsibilities
is because each the board is composed of
uh a majority of non-executives
and also executive directors on the
board
and the executive directors there are
four of them
including the head of news have a
function to
um
deliver as members of the board and
directors
to perform that function and it is it is
absolutely in the charter that the
nominations Committee of the board gets
involved in the appointment of board
positions so when I met Deborah Turners
it was following first of all she
reports as the directive news directly
to the chief executive who is the
director General there was a management
board that went through the process of
determining candidates so the meeting
that I attended in terms of the
selection of Debra Turners as a member
of the BBC was for quite properly for
her to be a member of that board
to fulfill those functions on the board
and it is in a requirement of the
nominations committee it is in the
charter of the nominations committee but
they should interview and be part of a
process of appointments to the board and
that includes the executive directors so
my involvement in the appointment of
Deborah tennis was precisely what I
should do as the chair of the board with
other members of the nominations
committee who sat on that session to
determine her capabilities to contribute
to the board as a director of the board
with that list of functions that I
outlined which are critically important
with respect to her position as director
of news she reports to direct director
General thank you chair okay thank you
Kevin Brennan uh thank you chair and
good morning Mr Sharp good morning just
to clarify something you were saying
earlier before you went to see Simon
case about this matter
I'm writing saying you did go and see
the prime minister to tell him you're
going to see yes and I've had a meeting
with the Prime Minister what did you
tell the Prime Minister you were going
to meet Simon case about I told him that
Mr Blythe wanted to support him I told
him that I'd advised Mr Blythe or I told
Mr Blythe and I'd formed him that there
are rules in this country and that
therefore as a result of that
um I he should be in touch with the
cabinet office and the result of that I
was going to do so but you did in fact
inform the Prime Minister I'm definitely
informed that there absolutely and from
the Prime Minister who has approached
you who wanted to lend him money to
support his lifestyle well I I informed
yes I informed the Prime Minister that
Mr Blythe wanted to be the cabinet
secretary to see whether he could help
the Prime Minister and the implication
of that is whether he could help him
financially yeah it definitely so
although you didn't offer direct
Financial advice to the Prime Minister
the point you're making earlier on you
did inform the Prime Minister before you
met the cabinet secretary that there was
someone who had approached you yes he
was a member of his family
who wanted to help him financially so in
effect without giving Financial advice
you had discussed his finances or rather
the fact that somebody wanted to help
him with his finances with the prime
minister
that's correct isn't it correct
can I just ask you is there anything
else you haven't told us
or hasn't been reported that might be
perceived as a potential conflict of
interest in relation to your appointment
with the BBC
you know I'm asking that don't you
because because you didn't tell us about
this before so I'm just just to clear
the air on that there is absolutely
nothing that you can recall
about anything that might be perceived
as a potential conflict of interest
related to your appointment that you
haven't told us or told the appointments
panel or told anyone you might be
expected to tell oh look I think in the
circumstances that's absolutely a fair
question and the answer is that having
had the meeting with Mr Case
on this particular issue and having
discussed the BBC application and that
Mr Case put in place issues to ensure
there was no conflict or perception of
conflict I did not raise it with this
committee when you're questioning I'm
going to come back to that in a minute
and just to be clear as well
have you discussed with anybody else or
did anybody else approach you or you
discuss with them ways that you might
assist Boris Johnson with his finances
Beyond sound life
is there anyone else at any time who's
you know discussing so so it's only Mr
buy that's right the sole occasion
correct
facilitating and he happened to be a
cousin of the Prime Minister and he
raised the issue of wanting to help the
Prime Minister and I told him he should
talk to the cabinet and I'll I'll come
back to that yeah I had no discussions
like that with anybody else despite your
previous answer I'm still not clear
why you didn't tell this committee about
your role in facilitating an
introduction to someone who wanted to
loan money to the Prime Minister yes I
had not clear why you can tell us
because I'd had a meeting with the
cabinet office I had a meeting with Mr
case I'd raised the issue of my BBC
application specifically with him
and uh he had agreed that to avoid a
conflict or any appearance of conflict I
should have no C nothing further to do
at that stage
the any support the Mr live is going to
provide was entirely hypothetical and I
I like to come I took comfort from that
discussion
she said earlier on and quite frankly I
don't think it's good enough to be
honest with you in relation to what was
expected of you as a candidate I know
you said you'd be scrupulous in the way
you went about this
appointment but if you actually read the
questionnaire that you filled in before
you appeared before the select committee
if you actually read the rules in
relation to what you should declare in
front of an appointments panel and so on
fact that
um well let me put you this way you're
asking us to empathize I think a little
bit with the process you went through
how about trying to empathize with
somebody who's a member of this select
committee whose constitutional Duty it
is
to examine somebody who's being
appointed as chair of the BBC for two
reasons one as to their competence to do
the job and secondly as to their ability
to do that job in independently with a
full disclosure of any information that
might call that into question and you
were probed quite deeply at the time
about your connections previous
political connections and donations and
the committee despite that was was able
to recommend that you did cross you
would you were above the line and you
were appointable to this particular
position but you hadn't disclosed to us
in full the potential conflict of
interest that you were required to
disclose by the rules that you knew very
well you were required to to disclose
which might have called into question
and at least should have been available
to the committee to consider in relation
to your potential Independence as BBC
chair isn't that an absolutely Fair
observation
I had raised
the issue of my candidature with Mr Kate
I know I know that I know that and I
raised it in in in with with I'm asking
yourself to put yourself in in our shoes
for a moment if you were sitting on this
committee wouldn't you be
just a little bit disgruntled
so I put it that way about the fact that
when you appeared before the committee
you chose not to tell us about this well
look I think one of the reasons why I'm
welcoming this opportunity is because
there's been a lot of
um
assessions about things that have taken
place I'm not making anything which have
mischaracterized
as far as I'm concerned my involvement
my involvement was to ensure due process
was followed
who I was not party
to any subsequent offense that took
place I gave no Financial advice to
prime minister I gave no Financial
advice well look we're going over old
ground but I'm not asking you that am I
I'm asking you if to put yourself in our
position for a moment you know and our
role in this matter
and if you were sat in the House of
Commons
whilst ministers prayed in Aid
this committee's report when he's
interviewed you in the pre-appointment
hearing to say nothing to see here and
when they're appearing all over the
media saying oh the dcms select
committee said it's it was fine so
there's not a problem and you're a
member of this committee and you find
out
that in fact you did not disclose to
this committee the fact that you were
involved in making introductions which
would result in a very large
soft loan facility being made available
to the very person
responsible for appointing you to the
job we were cons which was under
consideration how on Earth did you think
that was not a relevant matter that is
close to this committee well as I've
described you regret it as I've just
I'll come back that particularly as I've
described to you I did good faith to
ensure that first due process was
followed including an open declaration
to the cabinet secretary about the issue
occurring at the same time I was
applying to be the BBC chair
with respect to the regret obviously I
regret the situation I particularly
regret uh the situation that's a
non-regret regret that wasn't it no it's
not a situation at all do you regret
your actions in not telling the
committee that you had been involved in
this caper
the I I
I took at the time as I told you
um comfort from the conversation that I
had with Mr Case when was the blood the
issue resolved a conflict and a
perception of conflict
that's on the record so we can we can
read that back in the record when when
the supplied approached you about
helping the prime minister
did you at any point consider given the
position and the fact that you were
considering a man were actively pursuing
the position of chair of the BBC did you
actually
at any point consider the same simply
sorry I can't help
um
knowing that I'd had the conversation
with him in September when he called me
out passing the introduction to Mr Case
um
clearly you know I could have at that
time said no yeah why didn't you
um because I was I felt that I could
help ensure that due process was
followed did you think of saying I can't
help
because I'm in the middle of an
appointments process for a very high
profile public appointment share of the
BBC which by the way the Prime Minister
will have the final say over the very
person we're talking about
what kind of an idiot do you think I am
that I can in that in the midst of that
process that I would think it was
appropriate
to get involved in an affair of this
kind well I could understand why knowing
as he did that I worked in the same
complex as the cabinet office
and
um that he wanted me
to uh
make Mr Case aware of both his existence
and his desire to talk to Mr Case and I
felt that actually my participation was
to ensure the due process was followed
and the rules were followed I'll tell
you what I would have said yes to him
I would have said firstly it's not my
job
to have anything to do with bailing out
the Prime Minister and his personal
finances
and his unaffordable lifestyle
and I would have said more importantly
I'm a candidate for this key public
appointment
and I would have said I'm sorry Mr bride
you're going to have to ask somebody
else why didn't you say that
well that is why I proactively raised it
with the cabinet section we met
you're a member of his family
why don't you ask his brother
Joe Johnson who chairs the board of a
company
on which you sit on that very same board
why didn't you say
that to him
um I don't know John Joe Johnson
particularly well what I do know is that
Mr Blythe is a friend of mine Mr Blythe
and sits on the sits on he chairs the
ball with Joe Johnson of a company that
Mr blank this was during a very
difficult time in terms of people
meeting other people as you can remember
it's reported he's he's very close
friends with the prime minister of the
prime minister's father and brother as
well as being a family member didn't you
think saying why don't you go and ask
Stanley or Rachel Johnson well instead
of asking me he he knew that I had been
on the financial policy Committee of the
bank of England
he knew that I care about following the
rules carefully
and he turned to me for advice in what
would be a sensitive matter and he acted
on the conversation we'd had
their dinner where I told him that he
needed to be in touch with the capital
office he knew that I was in the same
operations
of physical operations as the cabinet
office and he asked me if I put him in
touch with the cabinet secretary when I
did
here's what I think
had I been approached in this way
about helping out financially the person
considering me
for and responsible for appointing me to
a a big controversial public appointment
as you already pointed out
I wouldn't have said sure no problem I
think I would have heard climbing alarm
Bells
and the dive claxson of a submarine
going on in my head at that point
knowing full well the process I was
about to Embark upon in relation to this
public appointment
wasn't it a Monumental failure
well I judgment on your part to go ahead
with this I did not believe
that ensuring that due process was
followed
was in itself a problem
um that's how you dress it up but really
you were you were helping out
somebody who wanted to lend money to the
Prime Minister when it was not your job
to do that no I was ensuring that Mr
Case was in a position to get the advice
before he would contemplate doing
anything
involving the Prime Minister see to me
it's just inconceivable
going back to the committee
that
in good faith you thought it appropriate
not to reveal your involvement in Mr
Johnson's
finances albeit as you've pointed out
that one remove
to the appointment panel when you were
going for this job and then to this
committee and I think
that any reasonable and fair person
would come to that conclusion would you
agree with that
I I'm seeking to lay out the facts here
and the facts are that a fair reasonable
person would see that what I was trying
to do was to ensure the duperative was
followed that in fact in introducing Mr
Blythe to the cabinet secretary
or seeking to introduce Mr Blythe
cabinet secretary I was ensuring that
somebody who wanted to support his
cousin was going to go about it in the
right way and that my involvement was to
ensure that due process was followed and
that was what I was seeking to achieve I
may be wrong but on reflection I would
have thought that a thoughtful person
like myself would realize that deep down
inside
it was the wrong course of action to
take and that you should have told this
committee about it but I'll leave it at
that
thank you Kevin Juliet thank you chair
um
Mr Sharp you've just said any fair and
reasonable person would think X Y and Z
you've said that you want to put the
facts on the record that's not a fact
that's that is your opinion I was
responding to a question yes but it's
not a fact it's your opinion yes correct
um and I would disagree that any fair
and reasonable person would come to the
same conclusion as yourself in fact I
don't know anybody that I've spoken to
about this who would come to that
conclusion now I don't know everybody in
the country but I know a lot of people
um
at any point even if what you did was
technically not breaking any rules at
any point during this process when you
were coming before this committee did
you did it not cross your mind perhaps I
should mention this
the uh candidly name
what what happened as you'll know from
I'm sure all of you have reread the
transcript of the many times and I
remember not just the words but the
inference that you were very blase about
or it was 10 years since you donated
anything to the toy party as if as if
this was some sort of distant long gone
connection
um and that you'd only donated a
relatively small amount of money in
political terms to one person but the
whole the whole manner in which you
answered those questions which I think
is as important as what you said was
that this was a distant long gone you
know I don't do this anymore kind of
thing well it was quite clear to me
um at the meeting
um that we had
that you were aware that I'd had an
understanding professional relationship
with Mr Johnson and that I had been
invited back into the treasury
uh to work during the pandemic and that
and that I knew Mr Johnson
professionally but you didn't think it
appropriate to mention that you'd as
you've said rang the Prime Minister and
the chancellor to tell them he wanted to
apply that that being this well that's
this transaction going on that you have
played a party and you didn't think it
appropriate to mention any of that well
that's why I took
um that's why I praised the issue with
the cabinet secretary and before I met
with you
I asked you did you not cross your mind
to mention this to this guy I'm seeking
to explain that if I may
um
I'd had a meeting before I met with you
which was I think in early January or
mid-January
um I'd met
in the beginning of December as I said
from this case and I think that the
details that meeting very important in
terms of how it influenced me in respect
to this particularity you're asking
um and
and the fact that I'd raised the issue
with him and he uh is the cabinet
secretary and also within the camp
within the sorry and within the cabinet
office is the proprietary in ethics
um gave me significant comfort in my
mind
when when we discussed that this was uh
that the process of being excluded
would resolve any conflict or
perceptional conflict it gave me
significant comfort in my mind that the
issue had been resolved
and that is why when I met with you as
far as I was concerned I had no part I
was no party to anything I had no part
in anything and the issue was not in my
mind with respect to a conflict and
you're asking what was in my mind
how this could be
I can see with the benefit of hindsight
particularly
um with some of the
possessions that have been made
um that that is a perfectly legitimate
issue for you to raise
and
the chair of the interview panel so
healing
um who's at the dcms told the Public
Accounts committee that the public
appointment panels typically ask whether
there was anything else that we ought to
be aware of which if it came to light
might embarrass either the government or
the organization responsible do you
remember being asked that question
um
the interview was two and a half years
ago
um I I and I don't remember all the
details but I think I do remember that
question being asked and I said no
and you think that
well I've explained to you precisely why
as far as my mind was concerned and how
and I believe now that that is why I
felt comfortable having had the
conversation explicit conversation it
was an explicit conversation with Mr
Case on this issue but my uh
introduction of Mr blight to Mr Case was
not in itself that particular issue so
that that was why as far as I was
concerned these two had been resolved
it might have been resolved but you
very very well aware of the of the high
scrutiny that your position that you now
called has and has historically had
anything connected to the BBC is under
huge public transcription
um yeah
and
it's a bit like when you you know if you
have pre-existing medical conditions on
an insurance form you might break your
leg and you might have a breathing
condition but they won't pay out on your
breaking your leg if you haven't
declared your breathing condition
did that kind of thing not cross your
mind that even if you think you didn't
do anything wrong and you might not have
done anything wrong did you not think
that well even though it's sorted and
it's happened and it's done that I
should actually just mention this that
people might be interested in this like
you and I think like the chair Mr and Mr
Nicholson it manifest that this has
caused embarrassment BBC and I regret
that and
um the I explained to you at the time
why I did not think so but it's very
clear particularly as this as my
involvement can be Mis mischaracterized
and has been mischaracterized that my
activities in seeking to ensure that Mr
blight met Mr case or the cabinet office
were involved clearly that activity that
I undertook before that interview
it's almost irrelevant what exactly
happened what what the exact
um you know
conversation who said what who met what
person whatever it's it's a fact that
you were involved in any way shape or
form in this this loan Arrangement even
if it was simply directing them to the
cabinet office telling the Prime
Minister that you were going to see the
cabinet secretary even if that was the
level of the involvement which is what
you say it is we've got no you know
reason to understand it's any different
even if that was what happened
yeah what I can't understand sitting
here is how you did not think that
applying for this job and coming before
us at pre-appointment hearing when you'd
got through the interview that at that
point that you something in your your
thought process didn't think well even
though there's absolutely nothing wrong
with this I need to be you know open and
transparent about all of my actions that
you didn't mention it that you didn't
you didn't think it fit to mention it
just just not adults well at that at
that time and and again I think you know
I appreciate the question at that time
um
as far as I was concerned
um Mr when I met with you
um this was some I guess some weeks six
weeks four four to six weeks after I'd
met Mr Blythe a sorry Mr Case
at that time as far as I was concerned I
knew nothing of any Arrangements that
were going to transpire and therefore
therefore I'm explaining to you I'm
explaining to you why as far as those
concerns are they are not really
relevant it's the fact that you you are
sitting there freely saying I had this
conversation I spoke to the Prime
Minister I went and had a meeting with
the cabinet secretary you're sitting
there freely saying I did all of this
that's the beat that should have been
sent to this Committee in my opinion and
that's the bit I don't understand why
you didn't do that well I'm explaining
had
because I'd had a conversation uh with
Mr case concerning the specific issue
and
um we had agreed that I would be
excluded in a way that in short that it
wasn't an issue that needed to be raised
or a conflict or a potential conflict
and I wasn't advised that that was
something that needed to be raised and
and at that time and I appreciate your
opinion now
um at that time that was as far as I was
concerned at the end of the matter
doing but that's how it comes across
that's what your answers sound like to
me that you just thought this is never
going to prevent I don't mean to mention
that is that not what you were thinking
thank you Julie Charles Watley thank you
chair we've got an enormous amount of
ground about who meant who what where
when why I'd like to move slightly on
you called for an investigation BBC
um
why did you do that well the the issue
that was raised was one of
um conflict and perception of conflict
and um
one of obviously my regrets of this
issue is that
um it affects the BBC
and therefore I felt it appropriate in
the circumstances
to reassure the people of the BBC that
there would also be an independent
investigation by the nominations
committee
no I won't be chairing that particular
um I recuse myself in that to
investigate that our declarations
are are in order
right what is that what you expect the
investigation to find that all is in
order yes but it's in being
independently reviewed and and that is
since your your appointment that
investigation will come correct and the
investigation by William George who also
recuses himself actually
um uh as Commission of public
appointments uh
what do you expect that to find you
um
I believe that I was appointed on
marriage
I believe that the
um all due processes were followed
um and I believe he will find that out
you said that this uh this whole matter
is a distraction uh and uh
and that you're really sorry about it
all you said that uh and having said
that in a view of your comments earlier
about perception
um
do you think perhaps that your position
as a chairman is now perhaps untenable
uh do you think that you can or do you
think you can weather this particular
storm
look I've I believe I've made a
significant contribution to the BBC I've
laid out the facts here and and I think
it's important to separate those from
the things that are not true
um and and I and the reason for that is
because some of the press has contained
significant inaccuracies
and on the basis of those inaccuracies
there's no doubt that that has had an
effect on some of the people for the BBC
and that's why I'm grateful actually
um to be accountable to you to subject
myself to this particular scrutiny
because I want to set this set the
record straight and
um you know I appreciate for example the
questioning
um from Miss Elliot
um the
um but it's very important
um to come back to the point that I've
never provided Financial advice to prime
minister that I'm not party to any
situation that arose and it's
speculative to know what actually
happened I have no knowledge of what
happened and that my involvement in this
was precisely to ensure the due process
was followed and
um that everything was done correctly
and subsequently I've had informal
confirmation from the cabinet office
that is their view of my participation
in this process
I recognize the difficulty that I put
this committee up under and I regret
that
um but at the same time this is
important because I wanted to create
some clarity because there's been a lot
of noise and a lot of
mischaracterization and a lot of uh uh
erroneous yes in sort of your defense
I'll say that in just a quick glance at
your CV
um uh you've been in charge of
governance of uh non-profit organization
ball Academy of Arts the Royal Marsden
Institute of cancer research uh Andrew
uh worked 23 years as a partner of
golden Goldman Sachs and it may well be
that you are absolutely the right man
for the job but despite that the very
fact that you're here answering these
questions today in public
don't you think it might have made it
impossible for you to continue well
fortunately
um I have had the chance to meet many
I've been in situated for two years
almost two years
and um and I do and I've met for example
all the employee Networks
um I've communicated in that sense uh
directly with at least half
um uh to two-thirds of the people in the
BBC
um I believe that they are no doubt
about my commitment and ability to make
a contribution to the success of the BBC
and in addition I think that they
understand my belief in public service
and the importance of it
um I think for example you will look
back a few weeks time and see my
um aggressive support and championing
the world service and the people of BBC
expect that from the chair and therefore
I do believe they
um whilst I regret what this this has
happened of course
um I do believe that people at BBC know
um that I'm striving to protect the
previously and preserve it and make it
successful and that I can contribute and
therefore of course this has had an
effect on the people of BBC but at the
same time
um notwithstanding some of the messages
that Mr Nicholson has had I've had a lot
of messages of support from people
within the BBC which I welcome and I
would say to any of the people who have
expressed their disquiet in text to Mr
Nicholson my door is open to them and
I'm happy to discuss this particular
issue with them directly I think you
brought into my next question thank you
Chad thank you Charles Simon John thank
you and good morning Mr Sharp um
throughout this entire session you've
mentioned
about press inaccuracies and Reporting
is the BBC guilty of that
um from time you mean in general or
specifically in relationships in
relation to this case they they
in in when they have repeated
um inaccuracies from
attributing it to other journals they
they are guilty they have been guilty of
that
um and
um they have subsequently made
Corrections if they found themselves to
be in possession of inaccurate
information
does that concern me
as the chair of the BBC the world
organization in which you chair the one
that you were tasked with you know
sorting out with regards to impartiality
bias all that kind of stuff
have in themselves failed their
editorial process in your view no I I
think the
um it certainly made me
personally more conscious
of the value that BBC in in striving
for impartiality and accuracy uh above
and beyond other organizations
um and
um
the and it's also made me aware of the
consequences of inaccuracy
um in a very personal way and
um
so so uh yes at the same time I'm proud
of the BBC in the way that we do report
and we will and we do we have done from
time to time got things wrong
and the issue in relation to that is is
how we address them when we get it wrong
and that we should correct and and
acknowledge our mistakes we will make
mistakes as an institution but we're
also I'm in my in my in my judgment
um both presently and in the future
Define ourselves as the most impartial
and accurate news but now you've had
this experience
you know uh
at the sharp end of the BBC's very own
editorial decision making
how does that impact on your role as as
chairman is that something that you
think is a potential conflict when
you're discussing this in the future
with members of your own board
yeah okay
um I'd like to if I may move the
conversation on to conversations you'll
have had with other politicians
um particularly the Secretary of State
for digital culture and media and Sport
for as long as that department exists
what discussions have you had with the
Secretary of State regarding the future
funding Arrangements of the VDC
well
um I've had a series of meetings where
I've sought to outline the beginnings of
our approach to our strategy and what
our needs are
um because I think funding should follow
strategy and needs it shouldn't precede
it
and and obviously one of the issues we
face is significant Global competition
and we also have a requirement to
provide a universal service
and we're operating in a very highly
inflation environment
so before the current pandemic uh sorry
before the current Ukrainian issue
caused unusual inflation issues the
media industry when the CPI was two
percent was already facing nine percent
inflation
and we Face a budget that in some ways
doesn't add up
and and therefore we Face very difficult
choices
and therefore I've felt that the sector
state
in considering issues associated with
the license fee
needs to understand and and get across
the detail of what we're seeking to
achieve and the budgetary implications
so that is that's the problem for a
conversation taking yes
um
how do you think that was received
the the me compensation you know setting
up your I think with great interest
right
yeah the sympathy I think it was
received yes I think it was a great
interest yes but of course excuse me
we're operating in a uh currently
nominal flat licensed fee environment
and that will only change in about a
year and a half
so
um I think we're really talking about
perspective prospective financing issues
rather than current bonds now in your
prayers although I should sorry I pick a
partner there's one thing I should add
which is what I highlighted in my speech
a few weeks ago which is as a result of
the budget we Face a considerable issue
in whether we can justify to domestic
license repairs the world service that
we do do in both uh to address a global
audience and to do it in foreign
languages for which license fee holders
directly do not receive a benefit and if
you remember
you would remember before the
discussions with George Osborne when he
was Chancellor that was separately
funded away from the BBC
um and and certainly I I I have made the
the uh Secretary of State aware
um but I do believe we will need
additional funding in order for the
world service to achieve its remit
successfully I think the good news is my
colleague Rupert is very keen to ask
questions of the World Service she'll do
so after I finish my session
um you previously described in the
pre-appointment hearing which we've
discussed a couple of times this morning
um the license fee is the least worst
option do you still subscribe to that
view well
there are there are issues
with the license fee
um it's regressive
um in some ways it's considered
anachronistic
um because
um
and there are other countries adopt
other mechanisms
and
um
there are a number of issues in terms of
how they fall on individuals both in
terms of how we collect the license fee
for example pensioners and also the
issues arising from people's failure to
pay the license fee including for
example how that falls would expect to
gender issues
um so it is imperfect
and um other countries are adopting
household taxes there are some Broadband
taxes
um and
um there are different ways to ensure
that the public service broadcaster is
separately funded do you have a
preferred option to replace it yeah no I
don't have preferred option now and I
also think that the BBC should
contribute to that
and that discussion when it arises
um but that really has a lot of policy
implications for you as representatives
of the people in making that judgment
understood now um previously on this
committee we've held a session with
members of BBC management regarding BBC
local radio which has been touching on
the license fee the license fee is
clearly paid for by communities and now
the BBC is looking to cut back on the
services closest to those communities
in BB's local radio when was the last
time you listened to your local BBC
Radio Station
um well I do
um I do listen to the local radio
stations and in fact I use the
um sounds if you like flywheel to listen
to other local radio stations
um
so
and one of the issues I do is because
actually in London to my concern uh with
all the competition we only have about
1.2 one and a half percent of the market
and so one of the things I do believe a
defining advantage of the BBC is
localism but one of the things I do in
thinking through the strategy for the
BBC is how we achieve that and when I
look at the market share that we have
um I have to ask myself as we think
about the strategy to delivering
localism
how we can do that and also maintain an
effective local radio station London if
I may is an isolated case with you know
historically low audiences through
several relaunches none of which have
worked but the um
more widely
services like the one in my county of
Devon are very popular with audiences
yes
so do you regret the the course the BBC
is taking which will for example
completely wipe out local programming
outside of sport every weekend on most
local radio stations
the I mean the conundrum we have is the
is where's the audience and where are
they going
and how we reach the local audience and
to deliver the local information
and and understand the conundrum and
having worked in local radio myself I
understand that but we are talking about
audiences that are not served by
any other service yeah because
local commercial radio barely exists in
this country anymore
and you know Community radio has popped
up across the country that's limited and
specific to certain areas BBC local
radio whether the BBC likes or not
targets and hasn't as a loyal audience
of people over 60 who listen to its
services yes look I think you know one
of the things that defines us as a
public service broadcaster has to be
effective localism there's no question
about that
and
um it is an issue of
um how we accomplish that that is a real
challenge
um because of where audience are
migrating to and where they're choosing
to spend their time
so the data is is incredibly important
in terms of the weather
the how the community will participate
with BBC output in whatever form and I
certainly hope get it right with a
combination of local radio in offering a
defining local Advantage but also with
our websites
so that people do believe that the BBC
is delivering to them precisely we
talked about which is a sense of
community and engagement on these
websites yeah it's been mentioned to me
several times by by editors of local
newspapers in my patch so that will
impact on their ability to maintain
their local paper because of course
local papers have you know diminished
demised across the country much like
commercial independent local radio
um so are you at all concerned about the
competition that we'll create and the
impact it'll have on the the printed
press that still exists in communities
like life well I've had meetings with
the local newspapers Representatives
and um
it's also clear that the BBC can act as
a channel
a website can act as a channel to
provide them with a larger audience on
their own websites
in addition what the BBC can do is also
provide some financial assistance to
local newspaper reporting and we do do
that
so I do think there's a synergistic
relationship that we connect we can
provide with more dedicated local news
entities like local newspapers or and
their websites
um by collaborating with them rather
than purely competing with them so for
example if there's a particular fire for
example in a particular Warehouse we can
put the limits before I hand over
um in a second back to the chair
obviously the original local radio
proposals were vast and cut swathes of
local programming the revised proposals
tinkered at the edges is that the final
situation for local radio is that the
the end of the discussion the end of any
movement on how those local services
will be portrayed in the next couple of
months those staff who are currently
facing the sac those programs that will
no longer exist that are loved by
audiences is that it well
broadly about I've explained that we
Face a real budget crisis for the BBC in
terms of I guess all that no no the
answer is quite direct so the answer is
the answer is no because if you take for
example a controversial restructuring
that's taking place at the moment which
isn't radio foil
there we have
um
put it out to consultation and we are in
discussions with the unions and we will
um as a result of that make adjustments
and we are listening and seeking to
ensure
um that we continue to deliver and we
continue to employ where possible we
haven't got much time because this
process is ongoing and and clearly you
know staff are under notice of
redundancy you know people are preparing
to lose their programs with an uncertain
future when will this be finalized when
we see yet another tweak from the BBC in
relation to local radio
well this is
a consequent of having a very difficult
budget having a flip normal
that we have to make we have to try and
achieve the same output in a more
efficient way and unfortunately
unfortunately that is accompanied often
by
seeking productivity increases which
amounts to fewer people doing the same
or doing more
but you haven't answered my question
when when would you given the process
ongoing given staff are currently facing
the sack or being moved around or jobs
that it want to do in different parts of
the country and there's uncertainty over
whose program will be done by which
presenter etc etc etc when do we expect
and you know the the final lineup the
final plan for local radio given we've
had two iterations already well look
like any Corporation
um we're having to constantly change and
create great productivity efficiencies
we've had to take 30 percent okay
in that sense it's never ending it's so
sort of what I get into is we're
constantly going to have to adapt to the
marketplace the needs of the consumers
uh our Our obligation to deliver local
public services and it's going to be
it's going to be it's a constant
management challenge
okay
back to YouTube thank you Simon uh Dr
Uber Huck uh thanks chair and hello
again Mr shark
um look I'm not going to rake over this
murky undisclosed loan gate because I
wasn't there in 2021 but
I mean can you see how objectively to
someone like me or to an alien from
another planet it looks like there was a
distinct lack of transparency
when you came to this committee and your
application was in that when the are
there any skeletons in your cupboard
question came yeah it wasn't revealed
look I I I can see now
with certainly with the benefit of
hindsight
that there there are facts
that I've shared with you about my uh
introduction
of
um Mr blight seeking my my seeking
introduction Mr blight was the case that
you weren't aware of
and I've heard loud and clear
that this committee wish it was aware of
it I mean are you grateful for the role
of investigative journalism in exposing
this because without that we wouldn't
know at all we'd all still be in the
dark well look I think it's
um as much as I'm at The Cutting Edge of
this and that's
I think it's one of the things that
makes this country great
and you would welcome more transparency
um
the the other thing is I mean you're
someone who's had dealings with both the
current prime minister and the previous
one is there a sense that um this could
be
passed in previous prime minister's
briefing against each other
because we know we've got a former prime
minister who's been to the US to Ukraine
to Davos in a
I'm still here away
I have to say most of my career is in
the private sector and in most of my
career
um
there wasn't
um if you like
leaking that happens in a sense in the
public sector domain
um so I have no judgment as to
motivations or issues or I have no
judgment on that I've no I really I I I
don't know what what the source of this
or what the intention behind whoever
chose to
a deliver a memo to these Sunday times I
I don't know what their motivation was
okay we don't know where it came from
and just my last little one on this what
do you see the role as the cabinet
secretary we know that you met him
without other officials missing it
just
curious to know well I the cabinet
secretary I see is the most uh senior
civil servant in the country
um under him comes proprietary and
ethics
and I see his role to advise
on any matters which
touch on
in this case the prime minister's
Affairs in so far
as they need to be managed in a way that
can form to the rules of proprietary and
ethics because it feels to me when I did
politics a level in the last century we
were taught that the cabinet secretary I
think it was Sir Robin Butler at the
time was the most powerful man in
England England and Wales Maybe
um and it was the head of the home civil
service but Scotland as well okay but it
feels like now it's turned into a fixer
for the for the government
sort of thing a fixer for the PM that
you can go and meet him behind the bike
sheds without it being minuteed
well that's what it feels like to me
okay um
look I think the cabinet secretary took
a minute of my meeting he took notes and
there was a memo that followed
um
so it was a meeting in the office in
that sense and it was you know a
disclosed and noticed meeting
okay I mean that's all I'll say on that
but here are for investigative
journalism
um I just noticed that BBC is currently
advertising for corporate Affairs execs
um
I think on pretty big salaries the most
recent ones come from Primark for
example so someone who's come from the
private sector it's really a good look
when you're sucking
journals and local radio presenters and
when huge
suedes of the World Service are having
the club pulled over
well I think I think we we have to run
ourselves like any
Corporation in one sense
and that is we do have to manage our
Communications
for example if you look at the situation
local radio how we communicate how we
manage our involvement with stakeholders
has to be professionally managed
and we need a team that can do that that
can ensure
that that takes place appropriately Plus
in addition we have to manage
communication with the regulator we have
to manage communication with Parliament
we have to manage our communication with
different governments
within the UK as well and we need to do
so professionally and that's why public
affairs is very important so that we do
that properly I'm a journalist friend of
mine you said that all the journalists
had communicated with you have been very
sympathetic but I represent a lot of
BBC staff I'm an ex-bbc staff myself I
have them in my family one of them said
to ask how much that corporate band e is
what sort of salary are these corporate
Affairs Executives getting
compared to your average journalists
well I mean one of the things six
figures isn't it one of the things we do
do at the remuneration subcommittee of
the board
is ensure that
um
the pay that we we make is appropriate
can you tell us in numbers
I I can tell you that um
I can tell you that
um we have failed to hire people what's
the kind because because we aren't
financially competitive with the private
detector it's a it's a great difficulty
for us to recruit
um people for key positions
at the BBC and in terms of the specifics
of that position I don't have that at
the top of my head and I'll have to come
back to you
okay I'd be curious to know you're going
to write to me about this on record okay
and the interview that you did in the
Sunday Times on December the 3rd when
you said the BBC should be run more like
Goldman Sachs and you'll know Marmaduke
um I think the title was more guts and
no liberal bias we know that part of
your job as chair is to uphold and
display independence from government is
this sort of
bias that you want to stick clear of
only liberal bias
no the fact that you it's very publicly
so for example Emily
I think you know
universally in this community
um people look at biases in the sense of
partisan political political issue
one of the things we've done
um is also look at thematic issues
associated and a lot of if you look at
Professor Sam Brooks recent articles for
example
he talks about the fact that the issues
about bias are not really part of it
around Party politics but they're around
issues of subjects so for example we we
had a thematic review
to look at impartiality in the context
of tax and spend which came out very
recently
we're going to have one
um I don't know if we've not yet our
migration example and part of our
approach to impartiality is to look at
it more broadly around topic areas and
how we approach topic areas
because and then I know for example the
Mr Nicholson has addressed this
um AI will be an is another source of
potential bias and
um if you uh if if if you look at some
of the
recent issues associated with AI as well
there will be biases cultural biases and
political biases emerging from those
areas as well so
so these these issues these issues we do
look at and part of my job is to ensure
which is why we've had the ten point
partiality plan is that we look at
biases in the broadest possible sense
and party political bias is only one
element of that and increasingly less
important to our audience and some of
the bigger issues
and when you say I will fight BBC
looks only in One Direction and apply an
applied example I want to give you um
Simon Job said I'm going to talk about
the world service
um we know that you just said actually
you will aggressively Champion them
World Service
but we know that it's a 85 years running
thing
um the relative cost actually of um 28
million it's 0.5 of your spend 0. not
not one percent of government spend it's
a tiny fraction compared to the soft
power that we get out of it we know that
these countries where
um news is censored
uh it's it's a vital Lifeline you know
this this is London Calling for years
and years has been the truth my cousins
in Bangladesh used to say we listen to
the BBC when we want the truth and there
is a suspicion that
so then so why is this being done I
think you could find the money down down
the back of the sofa it seems you know
when you're hiring these people on
six-figure Telephone salary type
uh telephone number type salaries to do
your corporate Affairs structures all
going in that way there's a report in
the voice newspaper third of February
that there was a call a zoom with Legacy
Africa they were told that they're all
for the chop no consultation is that a
way to treat stock somebody on that call
said this right-wing government
are moving away from engagement with the
continent of Africa so this seems to be
that you know what I mean you take one
bias and tilt it the other way and we
know in that interview you were fondly
talking about how Rishi sunak worked for
you in the 90s then he was your boss at
the treasury you have good mates with
Boris Johnson brokering his loan it just
all looks
I don't have the detail on the Africa
situation I'm talking about I doubt if
that is the case and I will look into it
I mean it just
substituting a previous bias for it
which may or may not have a good again
the attacks on Emily maitless who was
seen as an investigator journalist the
stuff that she did
with
prince Andrew are you not worried that
there's even a kind of brain drain away
from yourselves a lot of big names have
gone Andrew Moore Andrew Neal they've
all walked
well first of all let me makeless is a
very fine journalist I've always said
that and and I believe that so I
wouldn't want that
to be as characterized we have lost
talents of people and but we also have a
considerable amount of talented people
within the BBC to fill those positions
and it is often true that for an
organization to work you need fresh
water flowing through it
absolutely regret the loss of talent and
some sometimes that's Financial as well
um you know we we aren't competitive
with the private sector and um so you
know I'm touched and by the amount of
people who will work for the BBC
recognizing they could earn considerably
more in the private sector
but that the pressures of the uh pay in
inflation in the media market and over
capacity in our well-funded competitors
is going to continue to put a drain on
our resources that's unavoidable in the
context
of the financial constraints that we're
operating within and that is of
competitive issue for the BBC that we
need to be concerned about
I mean the decimation of uh local radio
that Simon jump referred to again that's
going to cut off the normal pipeline
that these people come up through well
we we are
um we're seeking to make local radio
more efficient we're not seeking to end
local radio
um and uh you know we we should always
remember that if you look across and
this is partly
um one of the things that inspired me to
come to the BBC the BBC plays a central
role in the whole creative Industries
we've lost if you look at many of the
independent film producers if you look
at much of the talent that's in the
private sector look at yourselves many
people came through the BBC and go into
other professions and that's part of
what we do as a public service to the
United Kingdom it's part of our training
exercise where we populate well-trained
people in the creative Industries and
that's something we should continue to
do as a public service broadcasters in
that sense
and in some ways
um welcome our contribution to the UK in
nurturing talent and allowing it to
flourish
Ed
in but it's the merger of the news
channel in BBC world uh gonna erode your
ability to serve
communities of the UK all communities of
the UK the fact that small quirky
stories find
exposure on BBC News Channel that for
you know it's a different audience
altogether you look there's no there's
no doubt that part of our Public Service
remit is to provide an adequate
um an excellent domestic news service
and this comes back to something we
discussed earlier this is an initiative
from the executive to create operating
efficiencies between our worldwide news
and our domestic news using technology
to ensure that as far as the domestic
audiences are concerned they receive an
adequate news I'm sure this will be
looked at by ofcom as well in terms of
Are We fulfilling our remit and it will
be looked at by the board in that sense
after we see how the final
um
product is delivered
and I'm sure that in doing it they're
conscious of the need to satisfy the
domestic audience that they're receiving
an appropriate service and will
investigative journalism things like
inside out survive this well it's again
it's up to director General to determine
which shows go forward and and not a
part of the BBC's remit will inch will
include I'm sure continue to including
investigative journalism both
domestically and and globally including
in Africa
and I'm grateful I think last time we
were talking about
um minority black and ethnic programming
and so there's been some u-turn on that
so I have to give you credit for that
grateful for that
um
but um can you give that assurance that
current journalists will have a future
in the BBC I think I asked you last time
and you weren't able to say so so we
know that there's been some rowing back
of the slashing of those programs well
this comes back to
making it clear the difference between
my position
as a non-executive and executive
the journalists
don't in that sense work for me
what is important as far as we're
concerned at the board
level is that the evaluation systems are
fair
and that people retain their jobs and
get promoted on the basis of Merit
and so I can't speak to the individual
journalists
and they should they should and do have
no more in that sense no more security
than they do in the private sector
but we have to have processes that
ensure that we retain the journalists
that we have on marriage yeah because
there is a worry about losing all this
expertise and apparently on this BBC
Africa call
journalists on there we're offered a
week's work experience sometimes people
that have given decades of their life
yes well I think that's one of the
things that makes BBC great is the
quality we've had of BBC journalists who
have actually had a period of longevity
and experience within the domain that
they operate
the domestic Channel sort of thing and
if all that squeezed out for
I don't know some Global Britain thing
that the government wants it's not good
okay last one from me
um gender pay we know that they were
well publicized cases 2018 Carrie Gracie
2020 Samira had won a Tribunal
in the last century I do recall Connie
Huck being paid less than her male
counterparts on Blue Peter I know the
gender gap is reducing is is there a
year when it will be zero I mean in our
jobs we're all paved the same thing
we're on a national scale
I mean gender pay is a complicated issue
and it also has to
look at functions as well so for example
it's well known that technology
there are more men than women
in that in terms of the the industry put
broadly
we have more than 50 employees now
who are women in more than 50 we've
passed 50 in terms of women at the BBC
um what is absolutely critical is that
people are paid the same whether they
are men and women for fulfilling the
same task
and get evaluated on the same basis that
is something we look at at the board and
if we find that the indicators
um
beg questions then we ask those
questions
so you are striving to yes absolutely
okay that could be a way to reduce some
of this reputational damage from the
murky loan affair
thank you
um I'm trying to pull things together
um and being as charitable as possible
you took an action that would make the
Prime Minister very personally grateful
to you while you were applying for a
sensitive job which was in his gift
and you didn't tell anyone about this
as I say being as charitable as possible
wasn't that an error of judgment
what Hunter took was to ensure the good
process was followed
um
I as I said I
sought to put
Mr Blyth in touch with Mr Case
and I then discussed with Mr Case the
implications of that
um
I had a long established relationship
with the prime minister
which was based upon professional
respect
I'd
I'd served actually
for him in two separate functions when
he was a mayor founded
and then in addition I was working on
significant activities
when I was in Downing street during the
pandemic
and so I was comfortable
in my mind that the Prime Minister knew
me professionally
and um that as far as I was concerned
the action that I was doing
was to put his cousin in touch
with the cabinet secretary and that is
as far as it went
so you would do it all the same again
well obviously I've had a lot of time to
consider in the last few weeks my
participation in this in seeking to
ensure that all the rules were followed
um
and I I wish we weren't where we were
where we are now
so you wouldn't have done well I I think
I will continue to consider the actions
I took what I do know is I acted in good
faith to ensure that rules are followed
and in that sense I have no regret for
that
um I I clearly underestimated the way
things could be seen
particularly in light of when they're
described with facts that weren't true
so for example I took I took no part in
any financing I took no part in
arranging the financing I wasn't party
to it I simply put Mr
lie together with Mr Case to ensure due
process was followed
and to that extent I don't regret the
fact that I formed Mr case that you
press this should be followed
um but clearly I could have said to him
as I think Mr Brennan said find your own
way to Mr Case
you wish you'd done that now
well I think you can you can form your
own judgment on that thank you um
Richard shell thank you very much for
giving evidence this morning that
concludes our session order order